come
closer have you I I've shared many
videos you have sem
ieto
person and they're going to spar or
they're going to do some demo match
against somebody from another
art or they're going to deal with a
resisting
UK and what you always
see is they go for a more direct
Center
manipulation so you see more koshinaga
variations and more
suaza okay where they
generate um in Sumi
Wasa a higher work output because they
use their whole body to go ahead and
pull on the
extremities okay then they get enough
power to move the center
or they affect the center directly like
kosin nag okay why why is that because
they can't touch the
center from here they can't touch the
center from
here what they do instead and what you
guys are doing now is in essence to
simplify it is you pull on this arm and
eventually that's going to pull the
shoulder and then that'll pull the
center you see
that that's what's Happening Here So
eventually you turn until eventually it
starts to pull on his skin suit you
understand that's not that's totally
different from this do you
see you get it okay so so some of you
are uh trying to do the yin hand here
and you're like don't have them and then
you
basically pull on this like his
skin eventually pull it
off you're just doing it down here like
this you're doing it here and you pull
his skin suit till it eventually pulls
the shoulder pulls the spine and pulls
the head and then the center comes you
see that and in that
delayed manipulation of the majority of
his Mass it never works it won't work
people resist counter and things like
that that's why those aikidoka don't do
that because they don't have control
over the person they have to do
koshinaga and Sumi waza
okay in Koko you don't want to just
throw them you're trying to have control
of their
Center there's no C without the II
communion at the tanden there's no
C okay so don't don't and do you
understand what I mean by skin suit you
like just pull the arm you're just
cutting the arm like that eventually the
person go but it will never happen when
they're resisting
okay um so for example if he lets go
okay and I'm here I'm going to have that
IE adhesion
do you feel
that uh I I have the I adhesion and
that's what's moving him if you pay
attention I don't have a ledge to pull
on you
see just because he's grabbing here I
don't want to seek
Ledges I'm doing an
adhesion here at
the contact
point and that's what m Mo
him put some
back
so I I'm now being
gripped but I'm moving that
immediately move
it move it
back
for
I'm not doing those
Ledges I'm not pulling him
okay try to understand that difference
because what I if you look at
iaza you have another
tactical
lexicon that allows you to control
someone but at arms
length but the assumption is that where
you touch on the arm you're actually
touching the
Center that's a huge assumption nowadays
because no one can touch the center from
the arms they they eventually pull the
skin suit and then that moves the center
eventually do you understand and that's
not going to that that that does not
meet the meet the Tactical
Assumption of kihon
Wasa he he does whatever do whatever
here we
go I have to be able to
touch is Center you understand not
pulling on a skin suit like you pull on
someone's key
okay I pull on his G and he moves he can
move his arm a lot I pull on his G
resist however you want or I'll kick
your ass you see he reinforces by
pulling on that
okay if you have for example I'm here
like this or let's say I'm here when he
when he goes to stand up you'll
feel
because I'm I'm in that IE communion of
Center I'm actually one of his basis
supports and when he tries to get
another Bas of support which he would
have to do to try to get off of the
initial control he's actually taking his
line of gravity outside of his base of
support and that's what makes him fall
okay that's a assumption that you can
touch the center from the extremity
directly not indirectly by pulling a
skin suit like you would pull someone's
GE okay so let's try it don't pull their
wrist okay
go in in your mind you are thinking that
you're tilting
him so we do tilting
heads which means they're on opposite
sides of his Center and turning the
periphery of his
body
here but if you pay pay
attention his arms
move ever so
slightly without his Center moving you
see that so here he is I don't affect
his
Center till about
here right so watch for that so you you
want to pay attention to his spine as
the most gross part to look but if you
can you can look at his Center too and
when does it start to be affected from
the position it is in now not till there
do you guys understand that is where you
are not in control of the person I'm not
in control of the person till there
okay this is incorrect energetically
that's not correct and martially this is
a misunderstanding of
kazushi you're not going to if you don't
control somebody in until you lean them
those first 40 35° is where you're going
to get countered Etc
okay so when when we're
here I I already have that Center
without any tilt do you see that and put
him
back move him this way put him
back he I'll knock him off and you'll
feel that I'm not letting you fall okay
so I'm going to knock him
off you feel
it okay so my hands might make one goes
up one may go
down but I need to have the uh control
so now as a hand goes uh up or down you
again see that he's moving
immediately you see his again look for
his
spine you see no movement no movement no
movement no movement no movement until I
get about there but as I do the other
one look at his spine is already
moved my hands haven't even gotten into
that same degree of
rotation so already from here I'm
already moving him do you see
already moving him and that's when the
hands are actually following
him which
means it's not that I tilted him and
then knocked him
over as he kept his grip and I take him
into that kazushi you see that that
shoulder's going lower that shoulder's
going higher you see which means this
hand's going up this hand hands going
down it's not me going like
this it's I'm doing
this and then staying with
him that's why this hand is high this
hand is
low here at the end keep it don't go
slap where your hands come in together
what you
keeping that feeling that same Center
connection move his Center follow his
hands keep the same Center
connection so he tries to get
up can't get up well I can't pick him
up
[Music]
okay so let's try that not just turning
the
wheel make that Center I
communion take them off
balance keep the I communion Center to
Center and just follow his
hands okay don't let your hands die at
the end your hands die at the end you're
going to lose the connection to the
center because that is the connection
point right now all right let's try it
again all right when you know the
inside the outside is not
important whenever the outside is
important you you don't know the
inside
okay but until you know the
inside don't f with the
outside so my hands are a certain
shape and you want that shape this is
not the shape this is not the shape this
is not the shape this is not the shape
is a certain
shape there's a cup to my
palm and there's a lot of energy
extension through these two
fingers my fingers are evenly spread not
weird stuff like
Spock evenly
spread my hand is not flat with my wrist
there's a
can here
I feel it most in this
[Music]
finger pay attention to that middle
finger so I do that same drill I'm not
going to be like
this thank things will happen so for
example he he's falling here on that
hand instead of changing my
shape I changed the angle do you
see he comes
up I keep that shape hand
shap
with
me
okay try it again all right uh the
yinan I think you have to pass through a
phase where you are just
externally pushing on the center get I
think you have to to get rid of the skin
suit idea
okay well when we when we affect the
center we're not just pushing okay do
you
understand because that'll never work on
the Y phase if you if you're externally
just pushing on the
center when you do a Yin phase in your
tabaki you're going to lose Center
connection because your hands come in in
the opposite direction okay so uh as for
example I want to he he's really strong
on one side or he's starting to knock me
over do you see and so you're going to
take off some of that with the yin phase
of some kind do you
understand so right here if you're here
and all you were doing was externally
pushing when you come
back you don't have the center do do you
understand so you saw how his he his
body came towards me okay as a easy
example but there's no reason why your
hand can't come back and is still moving
his body you
see you understand so in other words we
already talked about the skin suit and
uh he should be uh Center to Center
manipulation is happening on contact uh
and so in the same way that I don't use
the slack of his shoulders here until I
get enough tension in them to now pull
on his Center in the same way I don't
want to go here cuz nothing happened to
his body do you see until I now push on
their shoulders
again so as as if you pay attention this
hand is making a big
loop do you understand it should still
take him that way so I'm still in his
Center even on the yin phas got
it um there was one more I
saw that was the one that you used but
you did you did one too um
I think you came this
way yeah okay so you came
around and you came
down so pressure here but same
thing in the body in the
body not not after I take all the slack
of the skin suit and then I pull on his
Center in the
body
he's coming back towards
me you understand okay so pay attention
to the yin
phase it's probably where you're still
pull wa you know you're not pulling on
the skin suit but you're taking
advantage of the slack in the skin suit
do you guys get it okay try it again